We’re in the middle of a billion dollar
telescope building boom.
The Giant Magellan Telescope.
Thirty Meter Telescope and Europe’s Extremely
Large Telescope are all part of a new class
of ground based observatories that will peer
farther through space and further back in
time.
“Astronomers are not very good with names.
First we built big telescopes, and then we
made the very large telescope, and now we're
making extremely large telescopes.
But really what it means, it's about 10 times
larger than any telescope we have today.”
They’re all racing to see first light in
the 2020s.
But why now?
How did we get here?
“Typically, the size of the largest telescope
on the earth doubles about every 40 years…
Around 2000 there were groups around the globe
who had just finished building telescopes
of about 8 and 10 meters in diameter, and
they recognized the technology could be used
to make telescopes even larger.
And that was about the time... we discovered
that as astronomers we have no idea what's
actually going on in the universe.
I mean no idea in the sense that we figured
out that 97% of the stuff in the universe
can't be seen and we don't know what it is.
So that was a good motivation to build bigger
telescopes.”
“The technology got better for us to make
this quantum jump from, you know, eight meter
to 30 meter glass...This comes down to few
key elements.”
The first is a revolution in mirror size and
design.
“The telescope performance are mostly driven
by the size of the primary mirror.
The bigger the primary mirror, the more light
we can collect….That means we can go faint
into the universe, you can look at smaller
objects, more distant objects.”
The problem is you can't make one single mirror
any large than about 20 feet in diameter.
There's just basic material properties in
the glass that make it very difficult.
So...we have to make mirror segments.
We take the parent optical surface and kind
of like with the biscuit cutter we cut it
into seven circles.
We make them to one combined parent optical
surface that brings the light then to a single
focus.
We have to then hold those mirrors in place
on a large steel structure that's stiff enough
that it doesn't shake in the wind, and it
doesn't sag under its own weight, and then
it has to be precise enough to steer across
the sky so that when we move to track the
stars or the planets there's no vibration.
And we do that strangely enough by floating
the entire telescope, entire 1,000 tons on
a thin film of oil.
The telescope simply floats on that in a way
that's completely frictionless.”
That’s the design for the Giant Magellan
Telescope, whereas the E-ELT will take a slightly
different approach.
“The original idea was to build, not a forty
meter diameter, but 100 meter diameter.
And that was called the Overwhelmingly Large
Telescope, that was so big.
The engineers said "You know, this is really
too much for us.
The shape of the telescope has to be precise
to few tenths of nanometers.
So, the width of a hair across the entire
forty meter diameter of the primary, which
is, actually, not even one single piece.
It's made of 798 individual smaller mirrors.
Each of them needs to be polished, extremely
accurate, and then controlled extremely accurate,
to mimic this uniform surface at the nanometer
level.”
These enormous precision machines will be
built in some of the driest and most remote
places on earth, complementing space telescopes
like Hubble and the soon to launch James Webb.
“Hubble's pictures have been fantastic,
pioneering work.
But, they are somehow they've been pushed
to their limit.
So, what I'm expecting is this 30 meter telescopes
to do exactly the same revolution, as Hubble
did 20 years ago.”
But one major challenge these ground based
scopes have to contend with is our planet’s
atmosphere.
“The problem is the light from the stars
that's traveled for millions of years or sometimes
billions of years through the universe and
through the galaxy, when it hits our atmosphere
the light kind of wiggles as it goes through.”
This is what gives the stars their classic
twinkle, but it causes problems for astronomers
who want super sharp images.
This is where the next key advance comes in.
“Recently over the last ten years, there's
been a lot of development, what is called
adaptive optics.”
Here’s how it works.
Lasers from the telescope are shot into space,
exciting the atoms in the sodium layer of
the upper atmosphere and causing them to glow.
That glow acts as an artificial star that
astronomers can use to calculate the amount
of atmospheric turbulence.
Then, the mirrors will flex and deform by
computer controlled actuators to correct the
blur. “and, walla, you make sharp images.
The challenge is you have to do that 500 to
1,000 times a second and you have to do that
to about 1/20th of the wavelength of light
in precision.”
With unprecedented light-collecting capability
and advanced optical geometry, these new observatories
will tackle some of the most complex questions
known to science.
“There's been a lot of recent discovery
of exoplanets...We can see, more or less,
how distant they are from the planet.
But we would like to understand how they are
made of.
Do they have an atmosphere which is similar
to Earth, or not?
How do you form all these planets?
That's only one aspect.
Then, understanding how different galaxies
formed and evolved across the cosmic time,
you know for 13.5 billion years.
And then, we can move to cosmology and understanding
how dark matter and dark energy formed.
We are increasing the size so much, the capabilities
are so powerful that it will open completely
new discoveries in space.
And we don't really know where they will take
us, and that's to me the real beauty of this
new facilities.”
“Our telescopes while they might seem big
they're really small compared to the size
of the earth or the size of the universe,
so if we can collect more light, we have a
better chance of seeing those galaxies and
black holes back when the universe was less
than one billion years old.
And that's one of our key drivers is to look
back and see when did we transition from the
universe being dark, the end of the dark ages
to the first time it lit up, what we call
cosmic dawn.
That's something that all astronomers would
like to see and study the first light in the
universe.”
“The universe is a much bigger place than
just what we experience here in our daily
lives on the earth, and it enriches our lives
to simply understand that and to be aware
of it.”
Want more science documentaries?
Check out this one right here.
Don't forget to subscribe, and keep coming
back to Seeker for more videos.